he's not moving and he has a knee on his
neck and his
hands in his [ __ ] pocket so that
doesn't it already doesn't make sense
so obviously this guy derek showman is
not trying to go to jail for life
yeah but the evidence is so damning and
i was
surprised that they even had anything to
say at this point because it was so
blatantly obvious that he killed this
guy yeah and i'm not saying this from
this is not from like a racial
standpoint right i'm saying as this from
a civilian to see
in five four three two
one hello everybody welcome to an
episode
of the genius brain podcast if you guys
already know
my little genius brain farts hey that's
a good name for your brain parts yeah
the brain farts hey you guys are called
brain farts from now on
i love it my [ __ ] brain farts out
there man
ah dude i've been i've been looking for
something to call you guys man
the brain is cheers yeah well
welcome to the podcast is where we talk
about anything and everything and
everything [ __ ] goes because we're in
a world where everybody has to be
censored and i refuse
i [ __ ] refuse yeah just let us be
toxic males
like damn yes come on pray john leave us
alone
[Laughter]
let me tell you this [ __ ] crazy thing
that happened i actually forgot to
mention in a previous podcast but
it only it only jogged my memory because
you were talking about that freeway
story which would you
but um so when i came right back from
hawaii
uh i usually bike around south pasadena
right yeah
and you know you know when things happen
in the day that kind of give you a bad
feeling that
things are just gonna progressively get
shittier and shittier
so i woke up and it just kind of felt
like an off day
and i was like you know what i'm just
gonna get rid of my jitters by
going on a a bike ride yeah i forgot i
took off my my bike mount
so i went to go install my bike mount
and i call it khalif i'm like khalif
you want to go ride today it goes i'm
down cool and i already feel like
today's an off day
and uh i show up like 40 minutes late
and clean's like what happened so
apparently so when i was putting on the
bike mount
i was putting it on for like 30 minutes
i put on backwards
[Laughter]
whatever so i take it off and redo it
again
reattach the bike mount so we get to
biking right and there's a certain part
in south pasadena
um we kind of go through this trail
called the the arroyo seco trail it's a
bike path
and then there's a sharp steep hill that
goes into old town pasadena
well as we're walking uh we decided to
walk our bike up because the steep
the hill was too steep we see this guy
under an underpass
or the bridge that the the hill is under
and he has an angle monitor on
okay and he's going looking into a car
and i'm like
is this his car or is this not his car
and we're walking by him
and i don't know if his car or not yeah
right but it's under this bridge and
he's like
going through it and stuff and there's a
a car boot
the the bar that you put on the steering
wheel with the bootstrap yeah yeah the
steering wheel boot
and so me and khalif are like this guy
has an ankle monitor on i don't think
we're gonna say anything it might be his
car i don't [ __ ] know
so we just started going up and then as
we're going up
we are now on the bridge that that's
above a freeway and there's
[ __ ] crazy traffic when we look over
and there's a few other people that are
looking to see what's going on
um there's a huge car accident like on
the freeway
and we're kind of looking at it and we
don't know what's going on because we
see that the bumpers kind of ripped off
and then i get my phone to not take a
picture but to zoom in to see what's
going on
yeah and then i just see this motion of
somebody going up and down
up and down up and down oh [ __ ] and we
couldn't figure out what was going on
like what is that
white thing that keeps elevating up and
down up and down well they were giving
this guy cpr
straight up and i have never seen cpr in
person yeah
it's pretty aggressive oh yeah that's i
remember being told like just [ __ ]
break the sternum if you have to you
have to push the heart
like [ __ ] yeah it's nuts and so they
were giving this guy cpr for about 15
minutes
yeah non-stop and they had to switch
people constantly
because they were trying to revive this
guy and as they're giving him cpr his
stomach is
ballooning up and down up and down
that's when i got the visual of
this is actually pretty aggressive about
how cpr is this
this accident was nuts and then me and
khalif are looking down and we look at
the car right behind this accident
and it's a hearse and we go dude how how
weird is it that this person might be
dead and there's a hearse
yeah and so we're observing it and then
we go wait hold on a second
so there's a hearse in the front because
it was a funeral line
and so there's like 30 cars backed up
because they're there for a [ __ ]
funeral there's a dead body in that
hurry oh my god
and but they're stuck right in front of
this accident of this person getting cpr
trying to get back to life and i'm like
yo who
who the [ __ ] was the other car that got
into this accident and so we keep
looking and we're observing and then
we're like
okay the show's over this is kind of
crazy and so we started walking away
and we look back we realized that the
part of the car that we thought was the
front bumper wasn't the front bumper it
was a motorcycle
um so it was a guy that got cracked by a
car
in his motorcycle and that was the dude
he was on a harley yeah and that was a
dude that was getting resuscitated
oh my god because he got hit by the
[ __ ] car and so there was this line
of just 20 cars behind this hurts we're
like this is such a weird day today
and as we're walking i [ __ ] you [ __ ]
not there's a there's like a 70 year old
man
on a road bike dressed up from head to
toe and like the sleet
he looks like a seal like he looks slick
and then a truck almost hits him so this
old guy gets pissed
comes up and starts banging on his truck
like what the [ __ ] and he starts
punching his truck and so the the truck
goes on the freeway the guy on the bike
follows him on the freeway on his
bicycle oh
my god like how fast you're gonna go bro
25 miles per hour
so he goes he follows the dude on the
freeway and starts socking his truck i'm
like
what the [ __ ] is going on today this is
a bad thing this is a weird simpsons
episode it is
it's a weird what the [ __ ] and so this
is the whole day i was cautious like
none of this [ __ ] like connect but it's
like
what what is going on i've never seen
somebody so pissed off
that he would chase a car on a bicycle
dude yeah
yeah what the [ __ ] man i mean
i had a weird day too yesterday well
i was on a date went to the beach and
um we went to go eat korean barbecue
afterwards
and um she was like hey let's go back to
my place and we walked
there anyway so we were walking back
towards our apartment
in k-town and we're right in front of
her place
and she has her arm linked around mine
and then i just hear like that across on
the other side of the street and we look
and we just see and this kid
is crying and walking on the road now
right
down the street and this other kid he's
on a bike
like was just yelling at him in spanish
just cursing him out you know
and i'm like what the [ __ ] did you see
that and she was like yeah
okay and then i just kind of walk a
little faster to catch up
and then she pushed me and she goes go
do something
wait wait what yeah
all right so i [ __ ] went and i went
straight to the kid
and it was a girl it was this chubby
latina girl she was like five foot
nothing
right and she's crying and i said hey
are you okay
are you all right and she's like mmm i
didn't know what to say and i looked at
that guy and he's just in a
teenager too right and
he's on a bike and i look at her and i
said did he hit you
and she said yes yes he hit me and i was
like who is he do you know him
she goes he's my boyfriend i'm pregnant
and he just hit me
oh and i looked at that kid
i looked at him and he put his earphones
on and just [ __ ]
wrote off just yeah
like what the [ __ ] and then finally the
girl came and was just like are you all
right you need to watch whatever she got
hit
and then you look at her you go well
what did you say to him
oh [ __ ] dude i'm just kidding
i'm kidding i'm kidding it's not time
for jokes
no she's she says she's a student she
looked like she was 16 dude
she looked like a teenager the other kid
was teenager [ __ ]
what the hell is going on man [ __ ]
ruined my night
and what's with your date like why did
you have to be the hero she said
go do something what am i supposed to
let me tell you something if he hit a
girl he doesn't care about hitting me
yeah no that's another thing i was
wearing flip-flops still barefoot
like from the beach oh my god and i was
like okay
i'm not gonna [ __ ] chase this kid on
a bike yeah one and
the other one i don't know if he has a
weapon yeah and i don't know what he's
associated with or whatever but he was
scared enough to write off it's like he
just went i'm not gonna be like
man he's lucky i would have [ __ ] him
up yeah i don't know what the [ __ ] would
have happened yeah i was like
just hey don't do that
no literally the only thing was say hey
yeah and thank god he ran away because
that was enough like
dude what are you gonna say
what's gonna happen i had no idea that's
the weird thing too sometimes like with
when
when like girls have a certain
perception of what a man should do
but if you want to put it this in a real
life context what the [ __ ] were you
supposed to do
right i mean if let's say you walked up
and you go
hey why the [ __ ] did you do that he
looks at you and he goes i'll [ __ ] you
up too
like all right all right well uh but i
don't want to look like a [ __ ] in front
of this girl right
well we gotta see and then i would pick
up the girl and use her as a shield
like what are you supposed to do not
only that does this girl want me to [ __ ]
up her boyfriend
yeah no she's just was like leave me
alone i'm fine i'm
gonna that's like that's the best don't
don't call the cops why do you just
start beating his ass
and then she goes i love him and then
she starts sucking you in the back of
the head
like who knows all of that [ __ ] yeah
that [ __ ] guy just
look he's a coward is all i could think
but god damn like
i'm [ __ ] sad for this that's such a
weird
now you make me feel bad because earlier
today i was just telling mariel this
god damn it so i oh
this is my saving grace though before
people [ __ ] start judging me
so very nice neighborhood here right and
uh the neighborhood that i live in right
now a majority of the people here are
actually a lot older
yeah so they've owned these uh houses
for a very long time but now they've
appreciated in value they're worth a lot
of money
but a lot of the people who live here
are actually very old which is why i
like this neighborhood
it's super quiet we're the loudest ones
that we're not even allowed you know
so i go outside i have my my earbuds on
right and i'm about to go work out do do
some boxing stuff
and i don't i only piece this together
after the fact so i kind of heard a thud
somewhere
right but i wasn't paying attention i
was like in the garage going back and
forth back and forth
and i look over and i see this old lady
sitting on the concrete on the floor
and i just all i could think was why
would you sit on the floor like that
shadow boxing in front of them you know
but and then as i'm shadow boxing i'm
doing my thing right and i stop and i
look over i'm like
did she fall over i was like no
because i didn't hear her scream or
anything like oh my god but i had my
earbuds on so i wouldn't know
yeah so i just kind of kept ignoring it
i started shadow boxing and then i look
over again
and then you see her husband who's uh
another older gentleman look
he's kind of leaning over and he's
talking to her
but i'm not hearing anything i'm
listening to some dmx so all i have in
my head is
and you just hear you just see her
husband kind of tending to her or kind
of having a conversation with her as
she's sitting on the floor
then i was like maybe she is hurt but
what would i do
because it's rona they're older am i
gonna come up to been like hey are you
okay
or would they be offended that a young
person is asking if they're okay just
because they're old
so this whole thing is because if you're
old you don't want some young pug
like asking you what the [ __ ] is that
yeah it's like are you okay i'm just
[ __ ] city [ __ ]
so i started going through this whole
moral dilemma in my head yeah
of are they hurt do i think that they're
hurt just because they're old
and i'm thinking about this the whole
time and it was like the weed situation
because by the time i was thinking about
this i looked over and they were
like delayed gone as i begin to think i
think she did fall over
oh and then her jackass neighbor who
just moved in is listening to dmx just
shadow boxing
you know she just fell over and i did
nothing and now i feel like [ __ ]
now i'm embarrassed i can't go out there
anymore they know what it is man
it's like i had headphones on yeah i
didn't know
i didn't know but now i i'm i'm 100 sure
she fell over and she hurt herself
you think he was like did that guy help
you at all
[Laughter]
that's my fear that's my fear that he
thinks that i watched his wife fall down
and do anything
i just straight up wiped her out dude
yeah
and so i'm standing there you know and
i'm in the garage as i'm shadow boxing
my punches get slower and slower because
i'm starting to come to the realization
that she probably did fall down
and i just sat down oh man i am a piece
of [ __ ]
now i'm hell embarrassed and if she if
she walks out tomorrow and she's in
crutches
i'm gonna feel terrible oh [ __ ] and i'll
be like hey what happened neighbors she
goes you [ __ ] know you saw
you saw from the slit of your eyes i
know you look sideways
you saw me and i'll be like just because
my eyes are small
i was like i didn't see any of you in
your wide vision
let me tell you something i'm going to
immediately pretend like i'm deaf
but i have ear buds in my hair oh yes
today
korea yeah nobody paul in korea
yeah nobody ever paused in a courier
you never help old people in korea this
is very new
yeah but today's topic we're going to
talk about
something that everybody i don't know i
i haven't really touched on this subject
because
obviously last year with the with the
onslaught of the whole
you know the black lives matter ladder
black lives matter movement
which i'm very pro for and everything
else like that and this year has been
kind of for me anyways
uh i've made it a point to kind of care
about like my mental health and my
sanity
right not to say that when a lot of
social injustice happens that i'm not
gonna be involved in it clearly i'm not
i'm i'm not in that case i am always
involved i'm always
trying to think about the stuff but i
have been trying to take a mental break
from a lot of stuff that i've been
involved in
yeah but having said that it's been hard
lately because
everything is going down everything
everything there's just
more shootings than ever more shootings
more put them like a little closer face
i'm sorry yeah yeah more shootings more
more issues uh
but today specifically uh derek chovin
the murderer of george floyd is has been
convicted
um 75 years dude
the i think number three trending was
praise the lord
oh really it was like thank god praise
the lord praise jesus
all this stuff i got a bunch of texts
from people just saying just
giving us
you know this court case was so
interesting just because i was following
it very loosely but i was
going back and forth reading what the
prosecution and the
this podcast is brought to you by babble
my friends are you learning a second
language right now
if not what are you doing or as they say
in espanol
por que my friends porque i speak
spanish now thanks to babel
and if you're not on it you're a
freaking loser don't be a loser
get on babble but seriously if you're
trying to learn a second language and
you want to learn in a way
that is easy and fun you have to try
babble
babble designs their courses with
practical real world conversations in
mind
and things you'll get used to in every
day life other language learning apps
use ai for the lesson plans but babel
lessons
were created by over 100 language
experts that is a huge difference plus
babel speech recognition technology
helps you to improve your pronunciation
and accent because if you don't see it
right do you want to get made fun of
when you travel to that country and
you're like
esquired us as squared as my friends
what's that what's in the square does
huh well check it out
right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's
six months for the price of three just
go to babel.com and use promo code
gb that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code gb for an extra three months free
that's babble language for life
the defense is going through right and
it was the prosecution came to kill
like they came [ __ ] ready yeah and
the defense
and this is so weird in these court
cases because i wouldn't know what it's
like to be in that jury specifically
because everybody that they bring as a
key witness
or or somebody for the defense or the
prosecution
is an expert and then you as a jury have
to decide which expert you believe
and these lawyers have to dismantle what
these experts are saying
in a career or a field that they don't
know about yeah which is so [ __ ]
difficult
and what i was seeing is that the
prosecution was
way more prepared than the defense was
because they didn't have much ground to
stand on
the defense had to play their own video
of their defendant murdering
george floyd has their defense like yo
we're watching him murder him
how is this your defense like they had
nothing like in in the final closing
arguments it was just look at the video
yeah that's really what the main hitter
was like look at the video what more do
you need to see
and they were trying to share the angry
black man
case on with a witness like were you
angry and were you angry and were you
angry i saw that clip that was [ __ ] up
all these cases that came down to it and
it was basically george floyd came in
drunk
or whatever hi who knows i don't like
all that stuff was part of the case but
he had a fake 20 right and the guy the
cashier was like
this is fake bro like straight up the
ink's bleeding like and here's part of
the law
that i learned at my story you have to
call the authorities you have to call
the police yeah here's a fake no and he
said
yeah i got to keep this and he was like
no and he's like i have to call cops
he was like and they had their argument
the guy did what he had to do i read
about his like immense
guilt yeah he felt terrible i i saw him
he was being asked questions and you
could look at how uncomfortable he was
because he feels like none of this would
have happened if he just didn't make the
phone call
but the the thing is for us too it's
like if we want to be a part of this
society and the fact that we pay our
taxes
a lot of them as a business owner right
like i have to call yeah
it's against because i'm in trouble if i
keep that [ __ ] and put it on display or
some [ __ ] you know even
you have to turn it in so what i
learned to as i was seeing this at my
store
there's a airport right um
and it's where they skydive they do
racing
and it's just the domestic airport and
they film
[ __ ] sometimes there where there was
this film production
and they had a suitcase full of fake 50
bills a suitcase full of them right and
it got stolen offset
and got spread around town this small
little town
i saw that [ __ ] 50 every other week
you saw my stories
oh yeah right yeah i'd get these [ __ ]
fake 50s
all the goddamn time right i'd had old
men just like yeah i just sold a car
and had all these fake [ __ ] 50s i'd
be like oh you got
caught man oh my god i was like sir i
have to keep this
i have to and he understood right he
[ __ ] understood
every now and then someone comes in i'm
like this is fake dude i feel it i see
it
all the time i tell them story about the
case being stole
yeah these are counterfeit i have to
report it and they're
sometimes they get pissed give it back
give it to me or whatever and i'm like
no whatever you know you can't give it
back and i always call them
sure if some rep comes picks it up yeah
you have to give it
like to the federal government yeah
guess what no one [ __ ] died no one
got [ __ ] choked out
nothing nothing they came and picked up
the [ __ ] money and it was over they
didn't go search for the man cause
trouble for whoever is that who gave it
to me
even when they asked they say who gave
it to you is just like i don't know man
people come in and out and yeah they
take it it's not a problem
this george floor dying is just one of
those things i see
it happens it's [ __ ] i i don't know how
it gave it but it was just
that the part being choked out that's
true you know i never thought about that
because when we had the the fake bills
that came in right
my parents didn't know that they had to
call the cops right
or most of the time what would happen is
that we would take the money and they
would just
jet you know what was up oh yeah
jet hate when that happens i'm like [ __ ]
it's like yeah and they would jet and it
just is what it is right
but that was this is the interesting
part like when i was watching
what the defendants were saying and they
had like an expert there which i heard
he was kind of shady too or not heard
i was reading that he is being sued for
another case
you know what i'm not gonna even mention
that part you guys have to go read it
yourself because i don't want to put out
some
misinformation yeah but the there was
like a pulmonologist i believe
i believe it's called but either way
they were saying that one of the reasons
why he affixiated or he uh
he died from being choked out or
whatever was because it could have
possibly
also been a contributing factor of the
carbon monoxide from the exhaust
from the cars but they did a blood test
on them and they checked they did like a
hemoglobin test
and they said that from the oxygen
levels within his blood
that the amount of carbon monoxide that
he had in his system
was about two percent right right and
two percent is within normal range of
what everybody has in their system
which is zero to three yeah and
the uh the defendant was saying it could
have been up to 17 they're like do you
have documentation
that he goes no then what the [ __ ] are
you talking about guy
yeah what are you talking about you're
saying it yeah it possibly could be
anything
and this is where i started to realize i
was like the prosecution came to kill
and they brought their own experts and
they weren't ready
there was also another expert that they
brought in talking about how the the use
of force that he had
um could have been dangerous and could
have killed anybody no matter what type
of like
uh drugs that were in anybody's system
if it was just a regular
human being a person could have died
like that and they're also talking about
how
um when they brought in a an expert
witness for the defendant side it was a
cop who does cop training
he was kind of saying how in that type
of situation that cops have to use
excessive force because you don't know
what a guy will do
and you don't know what's in these cop
situations and they have to handle it
very differently
however if you look at the footage he's
not moving
and he has a knee on his neck and his
hands in his [ __ ]
pocket so that doesn't it already
doesn't make sense
so obviously this guy derek showman is
not trying to go to jail for life
yeah but the evidence is so damning and
i was
surprised that they even had anything to
say at this point because it was so
blatantly obvious that he killed this
guy yeah and i'm not saying this from
this is not from like a racial
standpoint right i'm saying as this from
a civilian to see a cop do that to a
civilian
blows my [ __ ] mind where you hear
this guy screaming for his life he's
saying
and yeah if he's hopped upon drugs and
stuff like that maybe they have seen
situations like this before
but he wasn't struggling no you
literally had your knee
on the back of his [ __ ] neck and you
choked him to death and you sit there
with your hands in your pocket like he
was absolutely nothing
and people i don't understand what the
argument is in the public eye
of how this is justified this goes about
one of the most important parts being
that he
apparently was a training officer he
trained
young rookies apparently which is crazy
which is crazy
and going to even the other the the
taser
gun mishap she was apparently a [ __ ]
train trainer too that's right so there
was another case
um not too long ago and this is what i'm
talking about how the world has been a
[ __ ] show
is with uh dante wright so dante wright
was a young
man he was being pulled over i believe
it was he
either had a warrant for for his arrest
or something he had
a warrant or there was he got pulled
over for expired licenses or something
yeah
um and he was being arrested or whatever
and the kid
tried to jet for it or go into his car
or run away
and that led to this lady cop who
was saying that she was i'm gonna tase
you i'm gonna tase you but she pulls out
her gun and shoots this kid
right terrible horrific accident
and what a lot of people are saying on
the defense of the cop
and this is the part that confuses me a
bit
where i understand what you're saying
but i'm saying it doesn't make sense
it's where the defense is you don't know
what it's like to be a cop
and when you're under stress and
mistakes can happen
okay here's the thing yeah you're 100
right
i'm don't know what it's like to be a
cop you know why because i'm not a
[ __ ] cop
and cops should be held to a higher
standard a way higher standard
so what are we really arguing about here
are we are we saying that
it's okay that this kid died because a
cop made such a
fatal and stupid mistake you should
still be in the cir
you should still be in the mindset of
the tragedy that happened versus
thinking well
hey this kid shouldn't have tried to
make a run for it whether he was trying
to make a run for it or not
if we just go boil it down should that
kid have lost his life
no he shouldn't have she knows she made
a mistake
it's a quote with that badge it's on her
it's on
her like that's what that badge is yeah
and they're talking about it as
as if it's unfair that we hold cops to a
higher
degree of standard it is supposed to be
like that
you are there to protect and serve
there's a relationship issue that we
have with our police force right now
even somebody like me who doesn't do
anything wrong right when a cop rolls by
why the [ __ ] is it that i get nervous
and i don't feel relief when i see a cop
roll by yeah and i'm not doing anything
now you know i think there is this weird
weird thing where yeah
we can keep saying you don't know what
it's like but i'll tell you this story
when i was in uh on my way back from
riverside
to uh to sacramento i got into this huge
car accident
because my buddy uh his name is scott
scott i love you to death but you're
[ __ ] stupid
this guy [ __ ] decided that he wanted
to drive us back home all the way
he believed in his driving skills scott
is by far if you want to talk about
the like the the racial stereotype that
asian people can't drive he's it
he's he's literally it this guy
was narcoleptic as [ __ ] but he believed
that he could make this drive from
12 am all the way till 5 a.m in the
morning all the way back to sacramento
right so he's driving i i knock out i
look at him he looks like he's tired as
[ __ ] and i'm like scott
pull over just let me drive he goes no
no i got it i got it i got it i'm like
scott just pull over let me drive he
goes no i'm good i'm like cool
i'm looking forward and i look to the
left and this fool has his hands on the
steering wheel and he's like this
oh my god knocked out and so
i'm like i grabbed the wheel because
obviously he's kind of leaning back and
i grabbed the wheel i'm like scott wake
up he goes
and then he turns the wheel hard right
we're on the far left side of the
freeway oh my and we spin out and we
somehow miss
all the cards and we [ __ ] fly into
the ditch
i get whiplash whatever so highway
patrolman comes by to pick us up to see
what's happening
checks in on us this is by far one of
the nicest highway patrolmen
i've ever met in my [ __ ] life yeah
he's like hey kids he's like are you
guys okay i'm like yeah we're good i'm
talking up till we're joking around
having a good time he goes
i'm actually retiring in like a week you
know you know he goes but
you know i'm glad you guys are okay and
i just you know we're chopping it up
it's like
5 6 a.m in the morning and i started
asking him questions yeah
this is a true [ __ ] story by the way
okay this guy was showing me
everything he goes yeah like he was
because you guys want something really
cool
scott wasn't having it he was freaking
out because he just destroyed his
parents car yeah but i'm like [ __ ] it
i'm here
and he goes do you guys want to see
something cool i was like what's up he
pops open the trunk and he shows us all
the tactical guns that he has in the
back oh he goes we actually have this in
the car with us i'm like dude this is
nuts
like shotguns and whatever and i'm
scared of guns and stuff too
and so he shows me he's either let me
hold his gun but he shows me the taser
that he has and he has the yellow taser
yeah and he let me hold it okay
i was like whoa i was like can i can i
hold that he goes yeah sure why not he
goes just don't shoot or anything i'm
like
what is this and so i actually found out
how um
taser guns work from that uh highway
patrolman okay and this is what i'm
remember remembering from when i was
like 19 years old so i could be wrong
yeah but i was asking him about how uh
taser guns
shoot and like how long are you supposed
to hold it and he goes well we don't
actually hold it when it releases
into somebody and the prongs shoot out
and it tases them
it releases for a certain amount of time
and we don't control that
yeah so it goes whatever five seconds 10
seconds oh so that's why they're like
okay
stop and they're like they can't they
can't it's already in there and it's
gonna go for that long
right um but he let me hold the thing
right and by the way
the weight of a taser is way different
is it lighter than a [ __ ] it's way
lighter
it's and by the way like her taser was
black it's plastic yeah
well it's got to be a russell shocked
yourself exactly it's [ __ ] plastic
and a gun is made out of [ __ ]
american steel
yeah so it's substantially different now
i'm not saying
that under duress that i'm going to be
perfect with this right let's say i was
a cop
i understand that but as a cop when you
are holding a lethal [ __ ] weapon
right and by the way
this officer she was she's not a rookie
yeah she was in service for like 20
years
a very [ __ ] long time something like
a police union rep or something yeah
she has been in the police force for a
very long time
so when we talk about a standard that we
expect out of a civil servant such as a
cop
and she's been in the force for 20 years
you're [ __ ] damn right i expect her
to know the [ __ ] difference between
her taser and her [ __ ] gun
if it was a rookie still unacceptable to
me
but i would understand it a little more
this podcast is brought to you by purple
my friends have you been sleeping
uncomfortably your whole life have you
been sleeping on a bed of rocks
straw and shame that's you my friend
because you haven't slept on a purple
mattress purple mattress
is my friends are backed by science
i'm talking about this bed keeps you
cool it keeps you
supported like your parents should have
it helps with your backs
your hips whether you're a side sleeper
or a back sleeper it doesn't matter
do you remember the days when you had to
go visit your friends or family
or if you went to a hotel and that
crappy bed done destroyed
your back and it blew out that back in a
bad way listen with my purple mattress i
gotta tell you something i was surprised
how i could sleep in whatever position
and your boy was sleeping like a baby
puppy
a big old baby bulldog korean big big
puppet
i loved it well check it out purple
really is comfort for an uncomfortable
world right now
and you'll get 10 off any order of 200
or more go to purple.com
gb10 and use promo code gb10 that's
purple.com
gb10 promo code gb10 for 10
off any order of 200 or more
purple.com gb10 promo code gb10
terms apply and there was a clip of this
other cop2 where he was talking about
he was kind of talking [ __ ] about the
cop it was another cop he goes that's
[ __ ] dumb you don't know the
difference between
your taser and your [ __ ] gun i said i
saw that one too right instagram live or
some [ __ ] and it's a cop saying facebook
live yeah
yeah that's dude okay
even what's his name pat robinson 700
club
he had a [ __ ] gun and a taser and
this this [ __ ] decrepit old man is
like
someone's got to do something did i do
not tell the difference between these
two 700 club
evangelist hard right wing police
supporter was even saying
what's going on all these young black
men are being killed
even he is getting woke now yeah even
like what the [ __ ] is going on
because if you're a gun activist and you
see that you should be ashamed of her
like you can't you don't know the simple
protocols for safety for a firearm you
can't tell the weight of a gun versus a
taser
that should be alarming and shocking
that a police officer didn't know that
yeah and in that case too whether or not
she did it on purpose or not
in my hearts of heart i want to say she
didn't do it on purpose
i'm still pissed at the fact that this
police officer who has been in service
for two
decades couldn't tell the difference
between her taser and her [ __ ] gun
and the only thing people want to focus
on is they're the uh the defense you're
the murderer
yeah i think straight up the only
defense is this is that oh you're not a
cop you don't know what they go through
you're damn str you are 100 right i'm
not a [ __ ] cop so i shouldn't be held
to that standard they should
yeah right this is a it's just such a
stupid argument
like i don't understand i i mean from
all the accounts like
with police being you know in in that
kind of service for long periods of time
like we have our
army veterans who are trained
you know like why is it so hard for
police to be trained like
i think one of the the most [ __ ] up
things i see is a fat cop
i don't understand that and i can't
understand it's like you're so
that's even that kind of standard like
hey man we expect you to
chase after someone yeah we expect you
to know combat at least
you know instead you're seeing like
straight power like being put over
people and i've never agreed with the
statement of
you know defund the the police
department and stuff
i believe whatever funding that they
have it just needs to be allocated
correctly whether it's in
psychiatric evaluations therapy
something there's something off here
right and there isn't any change about
it
and you know the sad thing about it is
is that
when there's one bad cop those mistakes
will always overshadow all the great
deeds that great cops do
yeah that's the reality of the situation
and that's why we see cops on social
media have to be like
speak out right yeah and then those it's
important for those who go viral too
we have to trust them still like the
whole a cab movement you know the all
cops are bastards
yeah ridiculous it's [ __ ] dumb come
on guys like
uh whether i know you don't like them or
whatever as an organization
and or even their horrid history and all
these things
the way the society works and where we
are today
we need the police yeah you know i mean
look at [ __ ] portland
yeah yeah like we were saying like
it's the just left left everything
just they're so they're they're doing
well out there in portland too by the
way i get pissed off about portland yeah
from seattle
i mean there's like sports rivalries but
every time i've been there i've never
had a good time
let's just say that portland to me is a
boring seattle yeah
with like fake [ __ ] food especially
but okay so i was taking a road trip
through portland
and um the protests were happening this
was june 2020. right
and we had um dan has these one wheels
right the single unicycle skateboard
thing
and i'm learning how to write it or
whatever and i'm going down the street
of portland and the protests are
happening right and we're just going
back to our car and we're going to go
back to la
and this white lady with this designer
purse
and a coffee in her hand is drinking
this coffee and i'm
i'm riding by her and as i'm coming she
spits her [ __ ] coffee in my direction
and i [ __ ] stop and i look at her and
she goes
the revolution is that way [ __ ]
and cops street walks towards a protest
you
[ __ ] karen [ __ ] what the hell
like liberals have karen's too man
that's hilarious this [ __ ] white but
like i'm sorry not what [ __ ] let's not
make it like that like this privileged
white lady
with nice clothes and all this drinking
of a [ __ ] nice
you know warm coffee in this day and age
doesn't like the world
revolution yeah and once a revolution
like
uh against the guy just going up in the
opposite direction like as if i'm not
for this stuff or whatever like i
have a road trip to get on you know did
you see that clip of the lady
in uh she was getting kicked out of a
nordstrom rack or a nordstrom because
she wouldn't wear a mask
so this lady she wouldn't wear a mask
and then she goes on to this
old diatribe in front of these two cops
about this is [ __ ] america her name
is cara by the heart
which is another derivation of karen so
crazy cara over here she goes i
i'm an american i don't like it that
you're stripping our [ __ ] rights blah
blah blah
and it's like listen lady you're not
getting arrested because you won't wear
a mask you're
this is private property you chose not
to do it then you shoved an employee
yeah so you
assaulted somebody now you're
trespassing so now you're going to get
arrested but she's trying to make it
this political statement about
what this country was happening in this
country they're being forced to wear
masks
whatever you [ __ ] assaulted a [ __ ]
employee in the store you dumb [ __ ]
what are you talking about yeah and so
she's like you people don't know
anything about america well i do know in
america you can't just assault somebody
and get away with it
and then she gets she's about to uh
recite something by the cdc she goes
the cdc we had enough of this and they
started
how can you how's this happening why is
this happening to me
exactly and like that always happens i
see this in the videos like why is this
happening because you're a
[ __ ] idiot yeah she goes don't you
know i'm not black
oh my gosh yeah she might as well just
say that like even the people getting
arrested
at the [ __ ] airport right for the
riots
they're they're they're in dc and the
cops are resting these people on
airplanes who are at the right side
they're like
what you're treating me like a black man
yeah they said that [ __ ]
like oh my god you're so [ __ ]
that's the crazy thing right like we we
are trying our best
you know during that time and i'm so
glad donald trump isn't present because
we haven't heard about this guy in
so long it's very refreshing but it's
very odd
or how coincidental that these people
who stormed the capitol who are so
pro-trump would say
such a ridiculous statement as why are
you arresting me
you're treating me like i'm black yeah
you know
like oh so you do see the world this way
yeah
oh why are you treating me like a black
person oh so you
see that there is a new yeah there are
some people like that but what are we
seeing is their entitlement
that i am supposed to be treated better
like hey i'm white
why is this happening there was
i mean to bring up something else too we
were talking about it were
and there was a lieutenant in the
military i believe he was a he's like a
part of the med side
but he was the lieutenant who got pepper
sprayed by the cops right
now this clip is very very weird um
i i was watching it and i just couldn't
wrap my head around it right
number one definitely this cop was on a
[ __ ] power trip
like i'll be honest i saw like the first
few seconds and i
had to turn it off and i just read just
yeah
what they did it was so weird because
at first i started cracking up because
this cop was on such a power trip
he didn't even know what the [ __ ] he was
saying put your hands outside the window
un unlock the car and then under your
seatbelt
how how how do you put your
hands outside the window undo your seat
belt and unlock the car
how made no sense on a power trip right
yeah and so basically what happened was
for about a mile and a quarter
i believe this guy wasn't pulling over
because it was a very very dark road
i don't think it's a smart idea get
pulled over by a cop if you're a black
man
yeah and there's no [ __ ] light might
as well so he pulled over at a gas
station and he was asking the cop what
is going on offer so what is going on
um and he had his registration on the
windshield that was in the back there
was a whole confusion thing that was
going on right
screaming and then what the officer was
telling him after everything was this is
on the body cam footage he goes want he
goes you need to empathize with me
i asked you to pull over it was a mile
to a mile and a half you weren't [ __ ]
pulling over
i'm scared that you might have a gun do
you understand he goes yeah i get that i
understand
but the damning part about that was this
it was
he started talking and say hey you don't
want to report this to like your
commander or anything else because you
know what there's gonna be a lot of
trouble for you me and you
so he knows he [ __ ] up yeah so he's
basically trying to plead to him like
hey don't tell anybody about this we'll
just keep this between me and you
because of how terrible he looks because
how terrible the situation
is yeah so if you guys haven't seen this
video basically what happens is he's he
basically
the the cop has a power trip and this is
my opinion
and he's threatening to tase this guy
right and he says to he goes
what seems to be the problem what is
going on here i'll tell you what's going
on you're about to ride you see he's
like you're about to er
ride the electric wave or something like
he was thor
right you know start saying this weird
corny ass [ __ ] line
arnold one-liner some [ __ ] yeah and he
has a rookie with him too and the rookie
sounds nervous like get out the car
screaming at the top of his [ __ ]
lungs his hands are outside the vehicle
by the way
right so he's clearly not a threat he's
in military stuff like that
he's talking to him super calm comes up
to him pepper sprays the guy and the guy
just takes it like a g
yeah right i mean they have that's part
of the training right yeah takes it like
a g he goes oh my god he's just kind of
just talking through it i'm like whoa
oh what the [ __ ] if somebody pepper
spray me yeah i'm screaming at the top
of my left
stop it stupid
like that body cam footage is going to
be spread all over the internet
[Laughter]
yeah i was like you know what how about
i don't sue you and you just never
release that footage
and we'll call it [ __ ] even guy dude
you just [ __ ] took it
and it's just he's just reasoning with
him telling him like hey we don't need
to tell anybody about this
right there was later footage that i
think i feel like the
uh the police force was trying to
basically disperse this lieutenant's
reputation because there was another
situation where he got pulled over
for driving like 19 or 20 miles over the
speed limit and he was also pulled over
for the same reason for his car
and he also didn't pull over for like a
half a mile or a mile or something
okay so then let's talk about this
military people who kind of rock their
military privilege is that a case of
this
maybe like somebody who really just
reaps the benefits
of wearing the uniform like i i'm in the
military i should be respected as such
it could be i see that behavior in
military wives
yeah it's a job description yeah my
husband
is in the military are you [ __ ]
the [ __ ] does it have to do with you
i've seen some [ __ ] on reddit where like
someone applied for a job and on their
resume was military wife
oh my god that's your [ __ ] resume
shut the [ __ ] up that's their job but
you know it's just that whole
like i'm not saying that this is what
this guy did right but the way that guy
was treated was
[ __ ] disgusting yeah it still wasn't
once again i don't know what it's like
to be a cop
and you know this is this is where the
argument will happen with everybody is
because he drove for a mile and a
quarter without pulling over
which in his mind i believe you know as
a black male in this country and it's a
dark road he wants to be in a well-lit
area i completely get that
and i also do understand just a little
bit about the cop who's nervous about
that situation
problem is is how he [ __ ] handled it
wasn't nuts to me
yeah it was nuts you're about to ride
the electric wave son
or it's like you wrote that 20 years ago
and this was
my chance and he thought it was so
[ __ ] cool pepper sprays this guy he
starts giving him a lecture
and then he ends it with a but we don't
need to tell anybody yeah cause you know
you [ __ ] up
like you know you [ __ ] up but now he's
suing the police department
yeah like what do we say about that type
of stuff you know
i mean there were times when like the
police helped me a lot
like because of all the [ __ ] i have
in my store they pulled up
um i told you about that sheriff who
would play my videos
of people like acting like fools at my
store for them
um but man there was one point that
where it happened where
it gets hard to trust them so
um this one [ __ ] [ __ ]
came with a hummer h2 right
and i wasn't there every time i'm not
there some [ __ ] happens too with my mom
and that's when i just get [ __ ] angry
too but like
my mom showed me the video clip they
pump gas
right they pump gas and our machines are
super old they're antiques
the old types where you have to pay up
front and you say you're going to get
this
oh wow yeah this was when gas was like
50 cents a gallon though
you know and that honor system those
tanks would just go
[ __ ] slow um they're antiques
these people paid 15 no five dollars and
put in 15
you know in a hummer and then their
proof was when they turn it on
the needle didn't go up you're driving a
[ __ ] hummer
yeah fifteen dollars worth of gas will
not move the [ __ ] needle
yeah not only that in trucks especially
americans it's like you drive it
and then the needle moves up slowly yeah
and it's like also too do you
realize that [ __ ] your hummer
it's it's literally it's it's like what
10 miles per gallon yeah
11 miles per gallon yeah on a good day
exactly and so this [ __ ] and all of her
friends who are out there too they start
braiding my mom i'm watching this on
camera and i'm [ __ ] pissed that i'm
not there
this is one of those complexes i had
with why i work so goddamn much
yeah i had to be there so no some
[ __ ] wouldn't do that to her
and so like i see this video i see all
this [ __ ] go down
and my mom told me the cops came the
cops looked at the video and said
your machine's broken i was
and they just left my mom and didn't
help but they're just like yeah your
machine's broken they didn't get gas
we look at the [ __ ] video look at our
machine that says fifteen dollars
yeah you know and that
that cop just was like wasn't gonna help
my mom she my mom told me everything
that happened showed me the video i see
these [ __ ] [ __ ]
put gas in their hummer and i do my
research
and i found out that this [ __ ] her
uncle owns the gas station down the road
right wow and i'm
first thought is steal his [ __ ] gas
you dumb [ __ ] cut
yeah you know and the other one was like
i'm going there
so i went i went to that store i was
like where's the owner of the store
who is you know he's like oh he's not
here we're just employees and i said
well his [ __ ] niece just stole gas i
owned that gas station down there yeah
you let him know that's what happened
he's like oh i'll call him
i did more research on this guy like two
beforehand
he became one of the heads of the city
council
because nobody votes yeah he just was a
shoo-in
that's hilarious and so the cops knew
when they found out she said my uncle
is yeah boss they [ __ ] let her go
and when i called this [ __ ] guy and i
showed up to his store to confront him
and he wasn't there and i'm like
talking to him now on the phone like
your niece stole [ __ ] gas
i don't know maybe she's still your
guess or whatever and he goes that's not
that's not me
that's not my problem oh wow what a
great civil servant [ __ ]
yeah that's yours he stole
[ __ ] gas yeah and then i
i called the sergeant the sheriff's
department
the city police and i called the
prosecutor's office the people who
helped me when i
you know had to testify for my
self-defense with that [ __ ]
yeah they wouldn't help me
that's when i kind of that was the last
year i was there and i
started losing my mind like yeah not
even the police will help me i mean
isn't that how everything works though
you know somebody that knows somebody
and they're not gonna do
[ __ ] yeah that's how everything is
everything is so [ __ ] corrupt right
i mean we talk about all these like
police force issues and you know i think
the the weird part of that situation too
is i think america is very good at
pretending that they're patriotic when
they're not
we are very good at pretending as if we
care about this country as
much as we do but there's a lot of
people who say it but they don't believe
it or care about each other and then
other americans
exactly because the idea of what it is
to be american is so
different from person to person to
culture we have no real nationalism here
yeah like
it just doesn't exist um or it does
exist but everybody's definition of what
it is to be a true or good american it's
it's
very very different from every state
every city every county
every party every part it's so [ __ ]
weird in this country right and so
because we i keep hearing over and over
respect your military respect your
military
right mm-hmm uh they they're dying for
us out here well you see this guy who is
a lieutenant
and by this police officer he's treated
like trash yeah and still the
conversation isn't how could you do this
to somebody
who is serving our country it's well why
didn't he get out the car he deserved it
and it's like your people's patriotism
doesn't mean [ __ ] in this country
it doesn't they only use it for when it
benefits them for example
i am a military wife [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you yeah i am the son of a pastor
i am the gateway to heaven how [ __ ]
dare you speak to me like this
yeah like that would be just equally as
like ridiculous people exactly
carry this nationalism and they're so
proud of
what this country has done right but
what the [ __ ] have you
done yeah you yeah you know that kind of
[ __ ]
that's not the most nationalist people
i've ever met it's people who actually
haven't done anything
but they like [ __ ] masturbate to the
military and the flag and all this [ __ ]
but they're just
they don't do [ __ ] with their lives and
also too i don't understand why it's so
hard for people to believe
that just because somebody has done
military service or just
because somebody's in the police force
that they're angels
they're [ __ ] angels it's just so hard
to believe that some of these people are
sick [ __ ] and weirdos and not even some
a lot of them are
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it's like it's
like do you believe that everybody that
goes to a university is a smart human
being
well when i ever meet like a dorky
[ __ ] cop
or like that bully dweebish cop i just
think about man i went to high school
with you
yeah you [ __ ] wanna be yeah you're
like loser poser
like hardcore just they're waiting for
somebody
to they're waiting for that moment where
they get to express authority
yeah power and they get drunk with that
[ __ ] dude i dude
obviously i'm not going to say names but
i know people who have
they're not my friends but they're
friends of friends who i've met who are
in the police force and you could tell
who these [ __ ] were
you were that short dweeby annoying
little [ __ ] that was weird that had no
friends
napoleonic content yeah complex exactly
and now you're in this power and now you
just strut like you're the [ __ ]
yeah and it's highly apparent when you
see it like um
chris oh had invited me out to k-town to
eat dinner with his friends like
um was that toban right and
i'm like 27 and they're all in their
mid-30s
so they're like older young types well
one of them is a cop
the whole dinner and he was only there
for like 30 minutes he was just
[ __ ] angry at liberals and
angry at democrats and he's a cop
downtown and all this stuff and just
[ __ ] on
like black people and even his wife was
just like
kind of like this [ __ ] the [ __ ] we
haven't even had our food yet
and then to a point who was just like he
got up and left i think he was just
upset with himself
he got embarrassed it was weird yeah
yeah it's like uh yeah
okay dude dude there are some people too
who let me tell you this man i was at a
at a wedding and there's this dude
napoleonic complex
as [ __ ] right and he's actually married
to one of my friends
and i don't really know this guy right i
just know that they got when i when i
left to la
they weren't dating yet but they started
dating after i left and i came back and
i met him a couple of times and he seems
like a really nice guy
but he's one of those guys that just
short dude that thinks he's a really
tough dude and
let me tell you something i grew up
around some tough [ __ ] dudes this
guy's not a tough guy
he just acts like he is or maybe he
knows a couple of people who used to be
thugs or whatever right
let me tell you how awkward this guy is
so we're at this wedding we're having a
conversation
and uh this is during the time
chick-fil-a
either donated money to the trump
administration or they said that
they don't believe in gay marriage right
right right and so all of us were
talking about like oh yeah
like i forgot the conversation came up
about fast food
right and then we were talking about
[ __ ] that we like and the other ones of
course in and out and somebody mentioned
chick-fil-a and we're like oh yeah
chick-fil-a's
sauce is fire yeah well out of nowhere
suddenly goes man
[ __ ] chick-fil-a dude
at a wedding well everybody's having a
good time
yeah and he goes [ __ ] chick-fil-a man
they don't believe in gay rights [ __ ]
them and if you [ __ ] eat chick-fil-a
[ __ ] y'all too
at a wedding table
what the [ __ ] are you thinking
and he's looking at me dead in the eye
as he's saying this obviously he's
saying to other people too but i was the
one saying that you're coming
[ __ ] jack in a box yeah what is his
moral stand that you're taking against
fast food right now
right he's trying to be like this super
woke cool guy and i love burgers aren't
even that good
yeah and i'm getting irritated right and
my best friend
looks at me right and he's just like oh
dave is getting mad yeah you know
not because he said [ __ ] chick-fil-a but
because of how stupid he was being
a [ __ ] lack of nunchi exactly and
he's just like
my brother goes hey don't say anything
and i just looked at him and i was like
i looked at him i was like dude you're
so [ __ ] stupid like nobody
[ __ ] cares it's a it's a chicken
burger bro
i was like we're just we're going i was
like dude there's so many things that's
more
morally corrupt with the [ __ ] that
you're wearing right now if you're not
gonna take the stand for that this is a
very odd thing for you to take a stand
about this right now yeah right
people are going to eat the sandwiches
if whether you're gay or straight or not
you can still eat the [ __ ] sandwiches
whether you choose to support it you can
support it or not i don't support their
views but i love their chicken
sandwiches dude the first time i saw
something like that
that was yo that was probably like 2012
2013 right it was a while back
yeah because same time uh we had this
big music video shoot for jason
chen and this other tiffany something
and um for uh catering we we got
a [ __ ] ton of chick-fil-a you know and
then she posted a picture
you know break eating chick-fil-a and
she got so much hate comments because of
that very thing
oh really and i just saw her because i'm
directing this video i saw her like
about to cry sitting there scrolling
through her phone
i'm like are you okay she goes
everyone's mad at me for eating
chick-fil-a and i was like
what just
just can you turn off your phone yeah so
we have to shoot this video she was on
the verge of tears
because she couldn't handle the
chick-fil-a beef the chick-fil-a
beef the beach that's so [ __ ] funny
dude
what is that i just like chick-fil-a
there was a there was a girl on jk news
she's i think she's chinese but she's
like a k-pop star okay
and she was making commentary so number
one
she i think she's international so she
travels from here to china
yeah right and so with all that being
said
she also grew up in like arcadia or
diamond bar i believe it was diamond bar
in that area
which is predominantly korean and
chinese yeah there is
basically no other ethnicity or race out
there if you go to those high schools
indian chinese maybe some japanese
korean taiwanese that's it so
when the it was a it was either a video
it was something about it was a video
about police brutality
i forgot where it happened it could have
been a subway or whatever what not and
basically her commentary was like
well how come they didn't she didn't i
don't understand like what's going on or
how come they didn't just
listen to the cops or something yeah
right and so i think everybody on j.k
news kind of explained like the cultural
nuance of what's going on in this
country yeah
she genuinely didn't know yeah and then
all of a sudden it was just cancel this
girl
i think her name was amber yeah okay i
do remember this event right it was
cancer her and all this [ __ ] it was just
literally
she doesn't no doesn't know yeah and so
it was it was a little disappointing
specifically a lot of jk news followers
and fans
not even fans i would say that the
negative people who want to take jk news
down
they speak very [ __ ] loud yeah and
they were just
trashing this girl for asking a question
who doesn't know about
a lot of the cultures here and you would
be very very [ __ ] surprised to know
that just because people live in la and
i've said this multiple times
la has a lot of cultures and languages
they are not
very diverse though in terms of how they
mingle together
right people are very separate here
people there are people
we talked about this there are people in
k-town
who are american that don't speak
korean but they talk like this
i was like dude look he's like you don't
have to speak english
and they're like i don't speak korean
because they never leave kate yeah never
[ __ ]
so they just speak the broken ass
konglish
here but they actually don't know how to
speak korean and they don't know how to
speak english foreign
man without a [ __ ] land wow and so
you know
she's not like that she speaks english
very well yeah but she grew up in a city
where it's predominantly
all asian people yeah and there may be a
few black people here a few white people
here
that's the neighborhood she grew up in
and if she's
you know traveling most of her life and
she's living in china she's not going to
understand
the the cultural plight or the the the
black play the asian-american plight
that people are facing here so when
somebody who doesn't know
asks a question how come the first thing
you should say is oh
she doesn't know because so that's why
she's asking well also
she said she's back and forth between
china and grew up around
like a predominantly asian surrounding
all around right yeah
what is it authoritarian right
we [ __ ] obey the authority yeah like
it's it's embedded in us through our
culture to obey
the authority and especially we talked
about this in mulan
yeah it was just authoritarianism
authoritarianism just hardcore that's
their values and even in the family
right and their government and for her
to say why don't you just listen to the
cops
it makes sense it makes sense yeah it
makes sense it makes sense but yeah
people jump down that poor girl's throat
for asking a question that she didn't
really know about
yeah if i i think because they heard
that she you know she speaks perfect
english they're like oh you're american
how come you don't know these things
well we could say that the other way
around i could ask every person who
didn't grow up around an asian person
though k-pop
is the biggest thing out here right now
you eat our [ __ ] food
you know your the clothing that you wear
has japanese the hip-hop clothing has
japanese letters over everything
yeah and i guarantee you you don't
understand [ __ ] about asian culture
whether it's japanese korean chinese or
whatever right
well aren't you [ __ ] american or
don't you watch or look at the clothes
you're [ __ ] wearing it's made in
china and japan and
[ __ ] indonesia everywhere else how
come you don't [ __ ] know that would
be the same thing
right you you don't know these things if
you're not exposed to it
we i think i said this last week right
being angry at someone who doesn't know
yeah you know just being like we should
stop being angry at stupid people
because they have the capacity to learn
yeah and if they're learning
why are you angry yeah a child not child
but a person who's learns
yeah you know like it's just doesn't
i don't know what it is it could be a
cancel culture kind of thing like a one
strike you're out like
not knowing off the bat is wrong yeah
it's ridiculous like yeah remember we're
saying too
there's people who just learned this
stuff last week and they come back and
now they're the [ __ ]
authoritative figure on a subject they
didn't know about a week ago it's like
you trash bag
who the [ __ ] do you think you are man
yeah that [ __ ]
bulk checking [ __ ] like i've gotten a
few times because
i'm talking with dan about like our diet
our our habits and this and that and he
and i
share our addictions yeah you know and
then we were talking about maybe we
shouldn't get into this because of our
addictive personalities
and someone who overheard us was in
their chair
turned around and was like actually you
probably shouldn't say anything
about your addictive personalities
because then you're just you know
avoiding and you're blame putting blame
on better
instead of facing did it just like look
back is who the [ __ ] are you yeah
the [ __ ] out of my conversation um are
you the one
with a drug problem yeah do you know
what it's like
yeah can you kind of see your way out of
this conversation first dude if somebody
just interjected into my conversation
i've just been like who the
[ __ ] are you we're just talking out our
thoughts i don't [ __ ] know you guys
back the [ __ ] out of my conversation
it's part of the [ __ ] la culture
especially in the art scene specifically
the liberal arts
scene like i'll be in some like wine and
music spot where people are showing
like their art it's curated this and
that right and people huddle around
scary conversations who's talking or
whatever and you have a glass of wine
right
and you know what they do yeah so um
yeah my dad abused me when i was a
little healed and he hit me
and then the other person is like yeah
um my
stepbrother touched me and the the and
they're doing
trauma olympics and they're seeing who
has the most [ __ ] up stories what the
[ __ ]
and i'm like i'm out of here
like people ruin good things
all the time yes like learn how to feel
your emotions it's like well guess what
i feel my emotions harder than you
[ __ ]
you know it's like my dad my dad used to
be me that's great my dad starved me
till i was 12.
and i don't know oh [ __ ] that yeah like
that like that kind of attitude i'm
sometimes just like
where am i who are these people so next
time i'm just gonna hop into that
conversation start making [ __ ] up dude
that's crazy because i lived in north
korea yeah yeah
um i had to make it through barbed wire
and he shot at me
i had a younger brother i ate him
[Laughter]
you don't know what baby tastes like
yeah just me and chris evans
oh my gosh i really know i really yeah i
really know what's better for you guys
[ __ ] well guys that wraps up this
episode of the jesus break podcast
uh stay woke out there people uh
what are your thoughts below about the
the derek shoving case what do you think
about
i'm so curious to see what people will
think about kind of
how to deal with the police situation
right because i will never ever say i
don't need the cops
i think that there's a lot of great cops
out there and without them i wouldn't
feel safe
yeah but you know i have an issue with
people not
being being not willing to express
that when things do go bad that it's
just plain out wrong
because how are we going to fix it if we
don't do it right right and we have to
talk through
every single factor yeah all the factors
before
and still to say we don't know it's
because it is hard
it is difficult and we accept that it's
difficult yeah
yeah shout outs to derek shelvin for me
in jail for the next 75 years guilty
[ __ ] yeah this was guilty he was
shocked too
did you see his face he was like oh my i
can't believe this is happening i i
believe it buddy
well you guys can catch ed at ed parkvp
and his podcast is
uh bible study at momo and then you guys
can see us every thursday sundays on
geniusbrain and we'll see you all next
time
peace peace